(calm synth music)
(music darkens)
(overlapping voices chattering)
(music crescendos)
(music ends)
- It was him.
Nah I'm just kidding.
(group laughing)
- Tell me about your last relationship.
- My last relationship was really chaotic.
- Describe your man.
- Describe my man.
They were a drag queen.
- "They"!
- Okay, okay!
Top energy, top energy!
(group laughing)
- Drag queens be tops, high key!
- That's what I'm saying!
Does anyone wanna talk
about their first time?
Like how- what happened?
- I'll go.
High school.
Only relationship I ever had.
- Okay.
- 23 and I couldn't get it in.
- Couldn't get it up
or couldn't get it in?
- In, in!
I can get it up!
(all laughing)
- Uh-oh, we found our bottom!
(laughter continues)
- We found our bottom!
(Joe claps)
- I look the most twink-y!
I'm like, they're gonna vote me;
I look like a twink.
But, um, I have IBS.
(music stops abruptly)
- Oh.
- I can't even get (beep) out.
Nothing's goin' in me!
(uncomfortable laughing)
- (chanting) Ready, okay!
T-M-I!
- I got a question for you guys.
Like, what type of guys do you like?
- Yes.
- I'm a twink lover!
I'm a twink lover.
- I like big, burly, cis men.
- You're a twink lover, okay.
I'm trans so I like to top, like,
specifically cis men
'cause it makes me feel powerful.
- [Jet?] Ooh.
- I like that.
- Yeah, and just like,
euphoric in my gender.
- What you doin' after this?
(all laughing)
- Are you a bottom? (laughs)
- Take my number!
- Oh my god!
- I like butch queens.
- Butch queens!
- I like both energies,
I like balance.
(group agreeing)
- I think recently I've
been attracted to like,
twinks for some reason.
I like to be more dominant.
(Grant and Apollo snickering)
- Who has bottomed before, ever?
Bottom, bottom bottom?
(group affirming)
- I feel like everyone
here has bottomed before.
(group agreeing)
- If you haven't bottomed, you're not gay!
- I will not,
I will not bottom.
- He's never bottomed.
- You've never bottomed?
I don't believe that.
- No, he can't!
- I've been in one relationship,
I've had sex once.
- He has IBS.
- I have no interest in it, I promise
I do not want anything up me.
- So, Grant is seeming a little nervous.
I see him sweating a little bit.
Grant, you're outta here.
I dunno, that's a little shady to me!
A little shady to me!
- No, no!
- All right, so who are we voting for?
(bell ringing)
(group murmuring)
(lively hip hop music)
(inaudible)
- [Crew Member] It was
actually a tie between
Grant and Art.
(exciting music)
- [Israel] I knew it, I knew it.
- [Crewmate] 60 second pitch, go!
- Yeah, I mean, I've tried bottoming
Like I bottomed a lot
and I thought it just made sense
for like who I was
and what I look like
and everybody told me I was a bottom.
But then like,
I realized I (beep)ing hated
taking (beep) in the (beep)!
Like, it hurts,
(Apollo laughing)
too much prep time,
like, it's messy.
It's just easier to be a top
and I get more pleasure out of it.
- We like them shorties as tops!
- All right, Grant!
- Let's go, twink!
- What you got?
- I know I look like a twink, y'all.
It would be so obvious
that I am the bottom.
But I'm a top.
I had sex- I topped for the first time,
I was in a long relationship
since high school
and he was bottom, I was the top.
(Jet tutting)
I see you!
I promise you will be
losing if you vote me!
I promise, I promise you!
(doubtful muttering)
- I don't know.
(upbeat synth music)
(buzzer sounds)
(disappointed groans)
- (sighs) Good luck to the bottom.
I'm fine with it.
I came in wanting to, you know,
get out the not obvious bottom,
but, you know, the people,
they didn't know how to
play the game like I did.
- So, Art!
- Yeah, why me?
(group laughing and clapping)
- I didn't want to judge you
based on how you look or anything,
but I just went with my experience,
'cause I didn't know who to pick.
- Okay.
- Aw, look at him laying it down now.
- Anybody else have something
other than what I look like-
- All right, do you like getting (beep)
or do you like eating (beep)?
- I love eating (beep)
way more than anything else.
That's like my number one thing,
is eating (beep).
- A real man likes (beep).
- That's a service top, though!
That's a service top.
- Okay, so what's one
thing that you assume with
someone who is a bottom-
painted fingernails.
I don't know, it's not
really a masculine thing-
- He's coming for you.
- He is coming for me.
- Does anyone have painted fingernails?
- I do, I have painted nails.
- Don't judge mine.
- I think that masculinity and femininity
really don't have
anything to do with like,
topping or bottoming.
- Right, right, I feel the same way.
Joe The Hoe From Chicago!
He mentioned about like fake fingernails
and painting nails
and I was like "Ah." (tuts)
And he's plucking'
around that bottom area.
Little bottom feeder there.
- What's your control level
in the bedroom?
Like do you want-
Are you more submissive
or are you more dominant?
Are you somewhere in the middle?
- I'm definitely more dominant.
I think that's why kinda
I'm attracted to twinks.
I'm not saying that they're not dominant,
but I just prefer to be in charge.
What do you prefer?
- I'm more dominant just because I've had,
you know, as a trans man,
sexual experiences
where I wasn't in charge
and I found that after my transition,
it's a lot easier for me to get off
if I'm in charge of not only my own body,
but my partner's body.
- So would you be willing
to let someone insert?
Would you be down with that?
- Uh, for schmoney, yeah.
(cash register dings)
- For some schmoney, yeah.
(Apollo laughing)
- So you are on Twitter?
- I am on Twitter, yeah.
(group laughing)
- Don't worry, he's "asking for a friend."
- Right, right, right.
- Are you interested, bottom?
(laughter continues)
- Maybe after this!
- Right, what you doin'?
- Depending on what position you're in!
- We gonna take the train!
- What about you?
- I'm very dominant.
Very, very dominant.
- Really?
- Yes.
- The pearls tell me differently.
- Oh, really?
- Do you get pearl necklaces a lot?
(all laughing, chattering)
- So what's your favorite
position in the bedroom?
- Doggy.
- Missionary.
- You said doggy?
You behind or the front?
- Front.
- Oh, you're in the front?
(record scratches)
You in the front or the back?
- Wait, you said you were in the front!
(group exclaiming)
- You're in the front!
If you're- are you in the back
or you in the front?
- It's too little.
I'm right here and then
they're right there.
- Oh, okay it's too little.
Okay, ah.
Come on, Joe, what's
your favorite position?
- I usually like doggy style.
- [Jet] Doggy style?
- Like yesterday when I
was at the orgy I kind of-
- You had a orgy yesterday?
I had a threesome last night.
- Oh, nice.
Jet, from the very beginning,
was very Chatty Catty,
and as we all know,
bottoms talk a lot.
He was kind of like, you know,
basically trying to establish dominance.
Alphas like myself don't
need to do anything.
- Front or back?
- Uh, back.
What do you mean?
(group clamoring)
I could do reverse cowgirl or something.
- I like missionary.
That's more dominant.
If you a real top, you like missionary.
- I like missionary but I like when like,
putting the leg over my shoulder,
so one leg over my shoulder
and then one leg laying down.
- You sure you can do that?
(Art laughs indignantly)
- You guys should try it out!
Demonstrate!
- Get on the floor, I'll show you!
I'll show you right now!
- Four seconds, guys.
- Two seconds!
- He's trying to throw it down, Jesus.
(alarm ringing)
(intense orchestral music)
- Joe, he seemed like very
outgoing and talkative
which are all things that
I usually see in bottoms
so it was kinda like,
stereotypical as well.
(buzzer sounds)
- Damn.
- Wow!
(group applauding)
- You did it, Joe.
- We did it, Joe!
- (laughs) We did it, Joe!
(all laughing)
- We did it, Joe!
- (fake sobbing) I
thought I was gonna win.
- [Crewmate] On three, raise your hand
if you want to keep playing.
One, two, three.
(all laughing)
- Let's keep this going!
- Has anyone ever been (beep) on?
- [Art] Yes.
(Apollo groaning)
- Absolutely, I've been painted!
- I felt like everyone was gonna say yes.
- Yes.
I was filming, actually.
Sometimes people just
don't always clean out
as well as they can.
- Yeah.
- (beep) happens.
(beep) definitely does happen.
Do you make sure you have
dishes for your bottom?
- Uh, no.
- No, you don't?
You're a horrible top!
- You make sure you have
dishes for your bottom?
- Hell yeah, why not?
- [Art] Yes!
- Do you guys feel like
you're more the aggressor
or you like guys coming up to you?
- I'm definitely more the aggressor.
I'm a Virgo, so I go after what I want.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I don't play no games.
- I'm a Libra, so I tend
to be indecisive about
when to go up to someone.
- Bottom energy.
- Nah, top energy.
(group laughing)
- I was suspicious of Jonathan.
Jonathan and Jet were
flirting a little bit
so I was like,
"One of these fools has to be a bottom."
- You said you don't like douches at all?
- No, I have a guest douche
for my bottoms that come over!
- A guest douche?
- A guest douche!
- That's a lot!
(Jet groaning)
- 'Cause you know, like,
the last time when that happened,
I'm gonna have a bottom
come over and they're like,
"I'm not clean, can we still do it?"
I'm like "No.
First of all, we are not doing that."
So I'll be like "I have
a douche for you ready!
Just go in there, take
as much time as you need.
I'll just chill out here
and then go do it."
- I'm a little suspicious of you, Art.
Because you have this little
like twunk energy going on.
I'm coming for you.
- You give me vers energy.
- Yeah?
(group agreeing)
- I can definitely see
you taking that dick.
- So I'm bisexual, I've
only dated one guy.
And once I was dating him I realized
I'm just a full top.
Like I was a vers because like, you know,
he was a vers,
so I tried to make it work for him,
but it just didn't work out.
So, I'm a full top.
- I feel like, in relationships,
sometimes you try things just because
you love that person.
- And it took a couple
months before I was like,
"Okay, let me just try."
- Yeah.
- Is there anyone that you
guys are concerned about
so we can just ask more questions?
- I mean, whatever, obviously me,
but I feel like-
(group laughing)
I feel like it's too
obvious that you're a top.
- So that's good.
I am a top.
- [Art] Hmmm, I don't know.
- You just said I'm too obvious.
- They could definitely
throw you in and be like,
"Okay, this is the bottom
but he doesn't look like
the typical bottom."
- I mean, I pretty much just
told you guys my entire-
Growing up, I always dated girls,
I'm bisexual,
just had one boyfriend.
(clock ticking)
Tried it, wasn't for me
and I just became the full top
in the relationship.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat hip hop music)
Voted for Israel.
At that point, I was just judging
based on the conversations
and I just went with the flow
and just trusted myself
and I voted for him.
- [Crewmate] It is another tie.
Art and Israel.
(dramatic music)
- Well I don't really feel like I
need to explain myself.
I feel like if you go around WeHo at all,
most of the guys there know that I top.
- He said track records, baby!
- Track records, babe!
- I do dress more feminine
and I do have more
feminine characteristics
'cause I've just started to
accept that for myself.
So, doesn't change my position.
- Honestly, I wish I was a bottom!
I think it would just make sense
with who I am as a person
and it would make it a lot easier
for my interactions with other men.
A lot of times guys
come to me and it's like
"Oh, I want a bottom."
And it's a lot of negotiating like
"Oh, who's more of a bottom here?"
And it's always just like,
I'm not gonna bottom.
It's just not gonna happen.
I'm representing for the
femme tops, the blouses.
I'm telling you, we exist and we're here!
(dramatic orchestral music)
(group laughing)
- This is sad.
- We've grown so close.
(laughter continues)
- But one of y'all lying,
so it's not that sad.
(buzzer sounds)
- Aw, bye baby.
(all applauding)
You had a good run.
- It didn't surprise me.
Femme tops exist
and I was just happy to
be able to say my piece.
- [Crewmate] If you
guys wanna keep playing,
but you keep voting out the wrong person,
that's a hundred dollars away.
Or you can be done if you guys think
that you have voted the mole out.
- I feel like we're good.
- [Crewmate] One, two, three.
- I ain't hear nothing.
(Jet snorts)
- You guys think the mole is out?
- If y'all are lying, (fist pounds)
in the parking lot, I'll-
(fists smacking)
- [Crewmate] If the box turns red,
the mole has won.
If the box turns green,
you guys have won and
correctly voted the mole out.
(suspenseful drum music)
(all gasping)
And on the count of three,
the mole can reveal.
One, two, three.
(drum roll crescendos)
(shouting and applauding)
- I knew it.
I knew it!
- No one thought it was me.
Everyone though it was someone-
no one thought it was me, it's so funny.
I just really sat back and played my swag
and I watched everybody.
I'm an observer, that's my Virgo energy.
And I had strategic questions that
only a bottom would know.
- The guy that I was
kiki-ing with the whole time!
He's got me pissed.
I'ma meet him outside.
(funky synth music)
- Look, everybody's like,
"Yeah, come outside."
I got my security outside in the car.
- [Israel] I'm finna rob him.
(all laughing)
- [Art] I'm about to top him,
what are you talking about?